bonjour à tous donc je suis mike
en fait j'ai un apprentissage très
classique j'ai commencé à 6 ans la
musique je me suis rendu compte très
tard trop tard d'ailleurs que mon corps
était esclave de ce que j'entendais de
ce que je voyais de ce que je ressentais
donc j'ai essayé de te travailler pour
déverrouiller les réflexes du corps et
j'ai découvert différents exercices
assez simple et qui ont mis en valeur en
fait justement tout notre
conditionnement par rapport à ce qu'on
voit à ce qu'on ressent à ce qu'on
touche à ce qu'on écoute à ce qu'on a ce
qu'on comprend parce que parfois le
cerveau ne joue énormément de tours donc
je vais essayer de voir ça avec vous
vous montrez un peu des exemples assez
concret qui vous permettront de réaliser
que finalement notre corps fait un peu
ce qu'il veut et parfois ça peut poser
de très gros problèmes quand on est en
groupe je vous demandais juste un
premier petit exercice je tape dans les
mains
huit ans donc je compte 1 2 3 4 1
chris est et après je ne tape lui mais
intérieurement je compte jusqu'au 8
vous vous allez essayer de faire ça
pardon et au bout de huit vous
recommencé à taper
on va essayer de voir ce qui se passe
parce que vous avez tous compris
oui on essaie ensemble lorsqu'on jusque
4 et on tape après les huis clos pour
être tous ensemble
1 2 3 4 et voilà
dans l'entente dit il ya un très gros
soucis déjà ses clés les huit coups que
vous avez imaginé intérieurement votants
de tête ou avec reuven votre pied je
sais pas la méthode employée nous a joué
des tours c'est que le voisin lui il a
pensé peut-être plus rapide vous un peu
plus lent dans l'ain qui a accéléré qui
aurait un autre qui a ralenti
donc ce que vous allez essayer de faire
là c'est de vous fier à moi vous
regardez bien mes mains moi je vais
compter intérieurement et on essaie de
repartir ensemble 1 2 3 4 et voilà
d'abus le piège je suis parti sur 7
vous m'avez vu jouer vous m'avez fait
confiance vous allez taper n'ont pas
tous heureusement donc là ce que vous
allez essayer de faire c'est de faire la
même chose
et quoi que je fasse vous comptez les
huit coups intérieurement et vous
repartez 1 2 3 4 vous avez vu des petits
exemples concrets
ce qu'on voit ce qu'on va entendre ça va
influencer notre perception de la
pulsation
c'est ce qu'on appelle la pulsation le
tempo et ça quand on travaille on groupe
c'est un peu la base on n'a pas de chef
d'orchestre on est obligé d'avoir
toujours une pulsation intérieur et ne
pas la perdre parce que sinon le
spectacle qu'on va prévoir de jouer une
catastrophe et on fera tout sauf de la
musique
donc ce que je vais vous montrer là
c'est un petit rythme que vous
connaissez peut-être les fans de
football
j'en suis pas un mais c'est assez connu
vous allez jouer ça
facile ok voilà donc on est tous
ensemble ça se passe bien
maintenant le souci c'est qu'il faut
réussir à jouer ça en ayant la petite
pulsations intérieur et à ce que là je
vais pas me rendre compte que mon corps
influence mon cerveau vous avez un petit
test
je vais essayer de taper ce petit rythme
en comptant une pulsation je compte 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 1 2 3 4
un ça va c'est facile pour tout le monde
ça ce sont les bases cirque on peut pas
envisager de jouer de la musique
si on n'a pas cette perception interne
de la pulsation je vais appeler un
cobaye donc c'est un des des membres de
mon groupe de percussions s'appelle
stéphane et vous allez voir on va faire
des petits exercices et vous verrez à
quel point le corps est vraiment
sensible à ce qui se passe et que le
maîtriser devient très difficile parfois
ses fans si tu peux venir vous pouvez
l'applaudir
stéphane est quelqu'un qui a l'habitude
de manier les rimes une très bonne
oreille musicale et donc je lui ai
demandé de jouer cette classe et je vais
essayer de le déstabiliser
est-ce qu'il a bougé 2 3 4 2 3 4 3 4 1 2
3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4
un peu est-ce qu'il a bougé on n'est pas
très bien c'est pas avec moi là ok stop
bravo eh bien
pas évident on est seulement sur des
petites rythmique qu'on joue avec les
mains après on peut se servir du corps
entièrement le souci c'est qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude d'utiliser son corps sont au
niveau des percussions et là j'ai fait
un petit exercice avec stéphane c'est de
travailler ses réflexes et de créer une
illusion entre ce qu'il entend est ce
qu'il faut réaliser
fermez les yeux au moins je tape des
mains tu tape le plus vite possible des
mains et quand je tape du pied je suis
passé à s'entendre est ce que tu entends
tu tape vite possible des pieds on y va
c'est bien ça va ok maintenant on va
inverser les choses quand je vais taper
des mains il va devoir taper du pied
c'est facile et quand je vais taper du
pied il va devoir taper des mains tu es
prêt
tabara j vous avez vu il a besoin
d'énormément de concentration pour juste
deux gestes très simples
donc ça sont vraiment les bases on va
essayer d'approfondir sa dont parlait
tous on a un métronome
le métronome disparaît stéphane va jouer
à cameron et continuer pendant le
silence j'essaye connu en rond c'est pas
mal c'est même très bien quand on joue
en groupe on a énormément à faire à ce
genre de cas c'est que nous on va jouer
une partie bien précise mais le voisin
va faire une autre partie le voisin de
gauche encore une autre partie y en a
qui vont se tromper ce qui arrive très
souvent malheureusement il faut qu'on
reste imperturbable donc à travers ça
c'est ce qu'on travaille là dire que moi
je fais n'importe quoi je suis
complètement arythmique je suis pas dans
la musique et le travail de stéphane
c'est de tenir une pulsation imaginé ça
que des rites plus complexe si on se met
à faire
les longues phrases comme ça déjà il
faut les mémoriser il faut les maîtriser
il faut avoir une plus que ses
intérieurs et imaginez quand le voisin
ou la voisine font un peu n'importe quoi
vous avez intérêt à très très solide par
rapport à ça et on se rend compte
justement qu'on l'ait pas très souvent
début je vais mettre un autre fichier
audio vous allez voir le métronome
lorsqu'on appelle le métronome reste
musicale salaires qui restent dans une
pulsation mais par contre il va se
décaler et vous allez voir que même si
quelqu'un joue un rythme qui est dans la
musique ça fait aussi nous perturber il
va continuer lui son rôle c'est de tenir
cet impôt là c'est facile et c'est fini
et là il est pas et pourtant le
métronome il est resté en musique
salaire que on avait une pulsation et le
métro d'un de ses miss lorsqu'on appelle
de contretemps entre les deux pins
pinpin donc si vous restez bien droit
vous restez en bonne relation avec ce
métronome et stéphane ce n'est pas le
cas il a été influencé par ce qu'il a
entendu
on essaye et 7e concentré s'il te plaît
j'ai une réputation à tenir
aussi super mais voilà il a réussi bravo
à lui
moi je me suis rendu compte durant mon
apprentissage que tout ça je l'avais pas
travailler j'ai fait une formation très
classique le conservatoire je lisais des
partitions à la chaîne et finalement je
vivais parce que je joue et c'est à dire
que la moindre perturbation qui était
dans ma bulle en fait donc je lisais la
partition je jouais il pouvait y avoir
la reine d'angleterre qui passait à
droite je la voyais même pas il ya
quelqu'un qui tombe et vous le voyez pas
et finalement je jouais pas en groupe en
fait j'avais aucune relation et que ce
que je joue et je ressentais rien et
donc à travers ces exercices on se rend
compte que il suffit d'écouter ce qui se
passe et on on vit mieux nos partis en
fait on arrive mieux à les gérer pour ça
bon comme vous avez vu il faut réussir à
ne pas être esclave de ce qu'on entend
de ce convoi parce que ce qu'on voit ça
peut énormément joué aussi
mais c'est un travail qui est possible
malheureusement il je trouve qu'il a un
peu délaissé
c'est quand même l'essence de la musique
un ressentir les choses là vous avez
juste un petit aperçu
mais on se rend compte que quand on
ressent et qu'on peut interpréter les
choses on fait vraiment une grande
avancée au niveau de ce qu'on joue et au
niveau du ressenti du public maintenant
je vais appeler deux instruments il ya
vincent et violette
s'il vous plaît
voilà donc là je vais vous montrer un
peu concrètement quand on est en
mini-groupe comment ça se passe ça fait
peur
voilà on tend à faire un exercice
les trois membres vont taper à la suite
avec toujours cette volonté d'être
aiguillé 1 2 3 je compte 1 de droit
vous y allez un deux trois ok super
maintenant
vincent tu fais silence tu te tapes
luttons coup on essaye 1 2 3
avec sa bouille et quand ça bouge pas ou
mon moral ça va être de les mettre en
danger
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 et voilà vous avez vu il
est dans une parfaite maîtrise
j'ai juste compter jusque 4 plutôt que
compté jusque 3 et c'est fini on
recommence vous avez à faire des
musiciens donc imaginer à queue avec des
personnes lambda on essaye 1-2-3 2.243 1
5 1 2 7 1 7 1 1 1 2 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1
2 rock et c'est fini j'avais vu donc
voilà donc à travers ce groupe on
travaille énormément d'exercice comme ça
au delà de la composition parce que
composé c'est très important aussi il ya
l'aspect créatif à traire les
percussions qui est très important on
invente des choses mais des bases sont
là c'est vraiment le travail et la
pulsation ne pas être influencé écouter
son corps parce que finalement on se
rend très vite compte que la
concentration et les coûts de son corps
nous permet de déverrouiller tout ça on
sait juste se construit des petits
réflexes tout au long de la vie et le
problème c'est que ça nous ouvre des
portes mais s'enferme beaucoup d'autres
pour que mon rôle c'est justement
d'ouvrir ses portes
ils se rendent compte que c'est aussi
facile que le reste on a juste pas
l'habitude on crée apprendre à écouter
réapprendre à ressentir et un peu
débrancher le cerveau parce que très
souvent ces cerveaux qui nous joue des
tours
un petit exemple juste pour finir
est ce que vous pouvez me faire ça
exactement la même chose et c'est un
raid pense ça je leur fais
il y en a combien antho il y en a 22 je
vous fais le même nombre de coups et
vous leur faites après la facile et
pourtant j'ai fait exactement le même
nombre de goût juste le placement de
silence à l'intérieur de ses coûts le
cerveau enregistre vous connaissez si je
fais tous les coups à la suite c'est
fini on est plus dans la musique ça
arrive aussi avec les nuances serre que
si je fais ça votre cerveau va
enregistrer la rythmique et va pouvoir
la reproduire si vous fait ça c'est le
flou total donc très important en
musique et je finirai à part ça les
silences les nuances c'est vraiment ce
qui va faire la musique le silence entre
les notes et les nuances et si vous
faites confiance essayer chez vous et
voudrait que le corps vous allez ouvrir
deux grandes portes et vous pourrez bien
joué en embêter les voisins dans l'avion
ou même à la maison
c'est assez intéressant à faire et ça
développe bien les réflexes voilà merci
à vous